saviez-vous qu'en voyageant de montréal
à paris en avion vous générez plus d'une
tonne de co2 mais il est possible de
compenser nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre en achetant des crédits carbone
plus concrètement vous payez une
entreprise afin qu'ils réduisent les
missions d g us en votre nom ça m'a aidé
à me sentir mieux - arnaud côté boisvert
a pris l'habitude d'acheter des crédits
carbone après chaque voyage
on peut le budget paix pour chaque tonne
de co2 générées ils paient une trentaine
de dollars carbone boréal un programme
associé à l'université du québec à
chicoutimi plantes ensuite cet arbre et
la pratique est de plus en plus
populaire la combine frappé et on a vu
un ralentissement mais depuis quelques
mois depuis janvier
plusieurs compagnies aériennes offrent
aussi de payer une compensation lors de
l'achat du billet d'avion des experts
constatent que les québécois semblent de
plus en plus conscientisés mais aussi
que les conséquences des changements
climatiques sont plus visibles une
réalité l'autre qu'on observe tout le
monde la sait pas faire de semaine est
celle des choses qui frappe l'imaginaire
l'imagination et qui font en sorte que
en une prise de conscience plus forte
mais attention les crédits carbone ne
règle pas tout il faut il de se
dédouaner avec ça c'est un outil parmi
tant d'autres mais c'est pas la solution
à tous nos problèmes l'impact des gs se
fait sentir aussitôt qu'ils sont émis en
contrepartie il faut compter une dizaine
d'années pour que les arbres captent sur
le co2 c'est un peu comme si à la
pharmacie on avait juste des pansements
qui est toujours beaucoup trop aussi
pour nos blessures ça prenait des
dizaines d'années avant que ce soit
assez grand pour couvrir l'ensemble
appelait on fait plus attention on
éviterait de se blesser et lorsqu'on
choisit de compenser il est important de
se tourner vers une entreprise fiable
les certifications gold tender et
verified carbon stand-up sont des gages
de qualité c'est pas tous les crédits
qui c'est qui va les en actions beaucoup
plus sérieux que d'autres ceci dit les
experts s'entendent vaut mieux réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
la base limiter nos déplacements revoir
nos besoins et finalement en dernier
recours compenser nos émissions ici qui
me permettrait au canada montréal